قال الكتور اشرف القدره المتحدث باسم
وزاره الصحه في غزه للجزيره ان اكثر من 62
جريح يحتاجون الى العلاج بشكل عاجل خارج
القطاع واوضح ان الوضع الصحي في غزه كارثي
للغايه وان مستشفيات جنوب غزه لم تبقى
فيها ايه سعه سريريه بينما المستشفيات في
شمال غزه منهاره
تماما نحن تواصلنا مع كافه الاطراف من اجل
توفير اليه جديده لخروج الجرحى ولكن للاسف
حتى اللحظه الاليه المتبعه اليه معقده
وعقيمه ولا تساهم في خروج الجرحى بالشكل
المامول نحن نتحدث عن اكثر من 6200 جريح
نحتاج الى خروجهم بشكل عاجل الى الى خارج
قطاع غزه ولكن للاسف الاليه المتبعه لا لا
تحدث اي تغيير في هذا الوضع وبالتالي نفقد
يوميا عشرات الجرحى من الذين ينتظرون
الخروج خارج قطاع غزه ولا ولا يوجد فرصه
لخروجهم حتى اللحظه